PROFESSOR: OK, so
we're good to consider,
therefore, the two cases.
So let's consider
the first case,
that this can be
pretty important,
this case one, when omega
fi plus omega is nearly 0.
In this case, what's happening?
You have Ef minus Ei plus
h bar omega is nearly 0,
or Ef roughly equal to
Ei minus h bar omega.
So what has happened if you have
a number-- so the question is,
when this happens, which
means that your omega--
that is, your perturbation--
is tailored to produce this,
then Ef is Ei minus h omega.
So you can think of
the energy scale here.
And Ef is lower than Ei.
And the difference
is h bar omega.
So what is this process?
This process is called
stimulated emission.
And why is that called
stimulated emission?
Because you're going
from a state of energy Ei
to a state of energy Ef
that has lower energy.
In that process, you're
releasing energy h bar omega
to the perturbation.
So it's almost--
you would say it's
stimulated because the
perturbation did it.
Still, it almost seems
like something the system
would do by itself.
It has higher energy.
It can go to lower energy and
emit something with frequency
with energy h omega.
But it does that only because
there is a perturbation.
If there was no perturbation,
this would not happen.
That's why, say if you consider
a hydrogen atom or a system,
it's not that the electron
that is in a higher state just
jumps by itself down.
It jumps by itself out
because it can couple
to other degrees of freedom.
And in particular, it can couple
to an electromagnetic field
and send out the photon.
So here, you have stimulated
emission of energy h bar omega.
So stimulated
emission-- emission.
And then the other term
corresponds to the case
when omega fi minus omega
is equal to 0, in which case
Ef is equal Ei plus h bar omega.
This time, Ef is higher
than Ei h bar omega.
And this process is
called absorption--
absorption.
You absorb energy h bar
omega from the perturbation.
The perturbation is capable of
giving the system energy h bar
omega to enable a transition
between Ei and Ef.
So this harmonic perturbation
has two tricks up its sleeve.
It can push you up
by giving you energy,
or it can stimulate you
to go to a lower state
and give energy to
the system represented
by the perturbation.
So two good things it
can do, and both cases
are pretty important.
So we're going to develop
one of these cases.
The other one has exactly
the same formulas.
And we need the Fermi golden
rule for this situation.
So that's what
I'll do right now.
To fix our notation, let's
just do the case of absorption.
But both are going to be
taken care simultaneously.
So absorption-- so what is C?
So when you're doing
absorption, you're saying, OK.
I'm basically having
this process in which Ef
is related to Ei in this way.
This term is becoming 0.
And this term is negligible.
So you can completely
ignore one term
when you're doing absorption.
And you can ignore
the other term
when you're doing a
stimulated emission.
You would say, oh,
but it's not exact.
What about if I keep it?
Well, there are many things
that we don't do exact.
This term is much
bigger than the other--
in principle,
infinitely bigger--
because we're going
to be integrated
over a narrow set of states.
So it would make no sense
to keep those other things.
Those other terms would
be much smaller, probably,
at even the next order
of perturbation theory.
So we keep, therefore,
the second term.
And so what do we have?
Cf of t naught 1 minus
H fi prime over h bar, e
to the i omega fi
minus omega t over 2.
You don't see that
term, of course.
But I'm going to take
out half of this phase
so that I get a sine
function out here.
So I took out half of the phase.
And then I get 2i sine omega
fi minus omega t over 2.
OK, that's this thing.
So the probability to go
from initial to final state
at time t naught would be
the C f1 of t naught squared.
And that's 4H fi prime,
because of the two here.
It's 4H fi prime
squared over h squared
sine squared of omega fi
minus omega over 2 times time
over omega fi minus
omega squared.
And this is all for Ef roughly
equal to Ei plus h bar omega.
So I didn't do much.
I really didn't do
all that much so far.
I just took the second term,
rewrote it with a sine,
and calculated its norm squared.
That's the probability to go
from initial to final states.
So the last step is
integrating over a final state.
So you have this sum over final
states of this probability
to go to the final state.
And we'll write it as the
integral over the set of states
rho of e final dE
final probability
final to initial of t naught.
And this is the same calculation
we were doing before.
And for this calculation, we
just substitute what P fi is.
We assume that as
we integrate, we're
going to have a narrow range
so that this function, rho
of Ef and h prime fi can
go out of the integral.
So what are we going to have?
I'll write it here.
4-- from the matrix
element, from this thing--
H fi prime squared
over h squared.
That goes out.
Then the rho of Ef goes out.
So I'll write it rho of Ef.
And rather than
leaving it like Ef,
like that, because it seems
like a variable, still,
of integration--
if I take it out,
I should be explicit
what this Ef is.
And in this case, Ef--
we're doing absorption.
So this is equal to
Ei plus h bar omega.
That's this central
contribution.
And that's where
you're taking rho out.
So this is pretty important.
This rho is evaluated
at the final energy,
which in this process is
h omega in addition to Ei.
And then the rest of
the integral dE f--
you still have dE f--
and the sine function.
So sine squared of omega
fi minus omega t over--
t naught, I'm sorry.
I'm missing t naught everywhere.
But I did copy it.
t naught and t
naught's up there.
Over 2 over omega fi
minus omega squared.
And this is the
story of the lobes.
This is the function that has
the lobes as a function of Ef.
As a function of
Ef, this quantity
varies and starts
developing the lobes.
And the lobes happen
for values of Ef
that are separated by some
h bar divided by t naught.
So this is the
exact same integral
we analyzed for the
constant transitions.
And it is the same
integral that we
argued that could be done as a
sine squared x over x squared.
So I will not do it again.
This integral gives h bar
linear in t naught over 2 pi.
When you study this,
you will have the notes
and you can review it.
If you've taken
notes, you will see
that is exactly
the same integral
we had last time, except that
we didn't have the omega, which
really doesn't change things.
It just shifts the zero.
So the peak of this
contribution is when
omega fi is equal to omega.
Before when we did it was
when omega fi was equal to 0.
That's why, in the
constant transitions
you conserved energy.
So with this result in
there, the whole answer
here is 2 pi over h bar--
h bar only because one
h bar cancels, indeed--
rho at Ef equal Ei
plus h omega H fi prime
squared times t naught.
That's all that is left,
which is great because that
is our Fermi's golden rule.
Remember, that's a
transition probability.
And the rate is obtained
by dividing this
by the time that has elapsed to
find the probability per unit
time.
That's the rate.
It's probability for
transition per unit,
times 2 pi over h bar rho
at Ef equal Ei plus h bar
omega times the matrix element
f H prime initial squared.
That's Fermi's golden rule
for harmonic transitions,
and in particular,
for absorption.
But stimulated emission,
the calculation
is completely analogous.
So the end result for stimulated
emission is just minus H omega.
The final energy
now is this one.
So the top sine--
plus is for absorption, minus
for stimulated emission.
And if you want a
reminder here, it
was that delta H was 2H
prime cosine omega t.
So this reminds you that
this H prime you have here
is the matrix element
of the perturbation
with this convention.
This omega you have
here is the frequency
of the perturbing Hamiltonian.
And that's what has happened.
So this is Fermi's golden rule.
It's over.
We've done it, done it
basically for two cases--
the constant perturbation and
the harmonic perturbation.
And there's a lot
of physics here
that we will be exploring
starting now, but continuing
with atoms and radiation in
general, atomic transitions.
W is the rate.
So this is called the
transition rate per unit time--
transition rate per unit time.
So the probability of
transition or probability
of transition per unit time--
probability of transition
per unit time--
that's probably more
understandable than the word
rate.
So this P fi gives you the
probability of transition
after a time t naught.
Happily, it's
proportional to t naught,
so you divide by the
time that has elapsed,
and it's a probability of
transition per unit time.
So once you compute
this number, you
get the probability of
transition per unit time.
So if this W is something
and you have a billion atoms,
you multiply that probability
by the number of atoms you have,
and you know how many
have decayed already.